hello everybody i'm kevin mccarthy at
the university of pittsburgh center for
vaccine research and today i'd be happy
to share some of our work over the past
uh year or so
that we've called sars kobe to evolution
addition by subtraction
so coronaviruses and stars cov2 don't
need a lot of background or information
i think everybody has all the details
but i do want to provide some insight
into our thinking as we began this work
about a year ago
so coronaviruses are widely distributed
across the globe um and they infect a
wide array of animal species mainly
mammals and birds
now these viruses are quite a defining
species in adapting to new hosts and so
these cycles of cross-species
transmission and adaptation can spill
over into humans with the bat to civet
to human transmission chain being the
origin story of sars kogi-1
or the bat to camel to human
transmission chain being the story for
uh mers coronavirus
and one of these days i hope we do get
to the bottom as to how the sars kobe 2
pandemic began
i think it is worth emphasizing
that humans aren't the dead end host of
this transmission chain and viral
adaptation
so we transmit the virus to the animals
that are around us as well and the virus
is then adapted to those hosts and
there's evidence of this in in ferrets
and in
denmark mink and every in other animal
species
so coronaviruses for an rna virus have
very very large genome sizes and in part
they carry around with them a battery of
accessory genes that are capable of
manipulating host cells
and to maintain a genome of this size
and scale they've evolved massive
polymerases that are multi-subunit
protein complexes
and they have a novel proofreading
activity so compared to other coronavi
or other rna viruses coronaviruses are
slower to introduce mutations into their
genomes
[Music]
so the spike protein is had considerable
focus put on it despite the fact that it
only makes up about 12 percent of the
genome and that's because it's the major
antigen that's on the virion surface and
it's the only defined target of
neutralizing antibodies
so the spike proteins arranged as a
homogeneous it's a homo trimer of spike
monomers so i'm showing one of those to
you in green here
and it's the factor that's responsible
for driving cell entry
and it's got a few important domains
that'll be key to this talk one of them
is the receptor binding domain or rbd
that's responsible for engaging its
cellular receptor which is ace2
it is a viral fusion and so its fusion
machinery is housed within the s2 domain
and there's a third domain called the
ntd that i'd say has
poorly defined if any functions that are
clearly attributed to it at this point
in time
and this is unique
to other
to coronaviruses and is generally not
present in related viruses
so why are we interested in spike well
antibodies directed to spike are the
strongest correlated protection that we
have to date in evaluating vaccines or
protective immunity elicited by
infection
most of the vaccines that are being used
today and deployed or under clinical
evaluation are
based on the sequences of spike from the
emergency of virus which came about at
the end of 2019 or early in january 2020
and we began this work uh in the late
summer of 2020 as clinical trials were
in phase three and we were awaiting the
results and the question was was the
spike protein going to change or not
and there's two ways that we could
envision this one was it going to adapt
in some way to the new human host that
it was in
or as immunity because of the pandemic
was building in the populations would it
adapt to evade building immunity
and really the only well-characterized
mutation was this d614g mutation that
caught a lot of attention in that time
and it's not at any host interacting
interface and probably manipulates the
way the virus enters cells
and so if this spike then were to evolve
it would be important that we know what
when that was happening so we'd have an
early warning as to what we'd need to do
with the vaccines we'd want to know
where and i mean genetically we're in
the genome where in a protein structure
and where in the world is this happening
and we want to know why that was
happening what was the the selective
force that was driving that viral
evolution
and then think about it how i i've
mentioned that this virus has a
proofreading polymerase and so
when it replicates its genome it
introduces mutations more slowly and so
what are the mechanisms that these
viruses use to adapt
and i'd say we were given a
a bit of a head start in thinking about
how this virus will evolve from this
tragic and fatal long-term infection of
an immunocompromised patient
so this patient had multiple myeloma was
given a car t-cell therapy that
basically removed all of their b cells
then they were unfortunately infected
with sars cov2 hospitalized
were given convalescent plasma and rem
desevere they got well enough to go home
but their infection then rebounded they
were readmitted to the hospital
and they never left the hospital
unfortunately they died at 74 days into
this infection
so
upon the
readmittance into the hospital here's
the chest x-ray showing severe lung
damage and at day 72 from an
endotracheal aspirate uh viral latent
samples were were collected from this
patient
and we use those in the lab then to
infect zero cells and propagate that
virus and so what i'm showing you here
in green is staining of those cells for
the spike protein
uh in red is the nuclear protein and in
blue is the nuclei labeled with dapi
and so we could propagate virus from
this patient
what we've since done is sequence this
virus and now that a number of them have
been deposited into the
gise database what we can see is that
the closest related sequences are
actually in pittsburgh where this
patient was treated and that's what's
underneath this green circle that you
see in the middle of the screen next to
plum
if we look then the next more closely
related viruses are in new jersey and
if you see in red here
the plt-1 is what we're calling this
patient's a pittsburgh long-term
infection one
has a longer branch length from the
other pennsylvania sequences and that's
indicating increased evolution
initially we had uh done sanger
sequencing on the i
viral material that was present in that
aspirate that we collected and i think
what we can see if you look at the
consensus sequence with the chromatogram
is that there's regions with double
peaks and there there's a clear deletion
within them and so that's an indicative
of a viral quasi species or at least a
swarm of different viruses in that
sample
we were able to resolve some of those in
the lines below
where the chromatogram is clean with
individual ta clones that we've had
showing that there were deletions at
adjacent sites
and so at this point in time we hadn't
heard about deletions especially not
mutations like this in the end terminal
domain
so we began
investigating more deeply in the gise
database and we pretty quickly came up
with a whole series of patient isolates
that had overlapping deletions with this
site or adjacent ones or even some of
the ones that were identical
and as it turned out with all of these
patients there were sufficient deposited
metadata there that we could
see that these were almost certainly
long-term infections of patients and
some of these had temporal sequences
that were deposited
now these papers have since all been
reported and that's confirmed our
initial suspicion
uh and i'll also note then that there
are deletions at a second site within
the entity that also came up in some of
these patients
so as we were looking we noticed that
there were more deletion examples and so
we used a more systematic approach
where we queried about the
145
000 sequences that were deposited at
that point in time and we identified
1100 of them or so that had deletions
within the spike gene
we then mapped their position and
lengths back onto spike and i think what
was quite striking is the fact that we
had four
hotspots for deletions
now we've named those recurrent deletion
regions or rdrs
one through four uh from five prime to
three prime
um and then i will say that you can see
a small bumps around where the junction
of uh s1 and s2 and that would be the
fearing cleavage site which also deletes
when these viruses are propagated
we can zoom in a little bit on the the
structure of what these look like and so
we noticed two trends here so one
typified by rdr1 and rvr3 where specific
deletions
or specific length deletions at specific
sites dominate the population
and that's why you get a strong peak in
the middle of each one
whereas for rdrs 2 and 4 we actually see
multiple deletions of variable lengths
and positions and so that builds up more
of a dome-like structure that made those
peaks on the previous slide
so we didn't
know what was going on here and we
hadn't heard anything else about anybody
reporting deletions and so we wanted to
convince ourselves that that this was
real
this was occurring in replication
competent viruses
and not some artifact
the first thing we quickly ruled out was
we didn't see any correlation of these
with sequencing platform and i'm not
showing those data to you today
but the simplest test was to say okay if
these were replicating viruses then they
should be able to make full length spike
proteins so so we created this histogram
that you're looking at here and integers
of three so three six nine should all be
more common because they would preserve
the reading frame
versus those that would inactivate it
causing a frame shift
and so that that turns out to be true
and if anything there's enrichment for
the deletions that preserve the reading
frame as you get longer and longer in
line
we then did a little bit more of a
sophisticated analysis
where we not only looked at maintaining
an open reading frame but those
deletions that resolved without the
introduction of a stop codon
and so
two out of every three deletions should
alter the reading frame and then a
certain percentage of those should
resolve with the stop codon and instead
what we saw overall for the deletion
variants that we identified that about
90 of them maintained an open reading
frame and i think this was the first
evidence that we had that this was real
and occurring in the context of
replication competent viruses
and also that the
selection was favoring these variants
that we were observing
and it's not uniformly true if we look
at the receptor binding domain or rbd
it's only about 30 percent of those
deletions resolve in frame without a
stop codon
uh similarly with s2 and it's really the
rdrs in the ntd that are heavily
enriched for deletions that maintain an
open reading frame
uh in the it drops down to about 50
outside of those domains within the ntd
so we wanted to know are these arising
individual patients or these being
transmitted between patients and so
using metadata that was deposited with
these sequences and the strict criteria
that the patients had to be
within the same country around the same
time
because we identif and they had to be
distinguishable so we needed to be able
to distinguish between two of the at
least two patients
we found clear examples of transmission
of each of a deletion at each one of
these sites so two sequences that were
identical in france
uh from a male and female of different
ages we found transmission clusters of
other rdr variants within senegal
ireland switzerland
and so what that last slide suggested is
that these were occurring all over the
world and in different genetic
backgrounds and that turns out to be
true so we looked at the geographic and
genetic distributions of these deletion
variants and again we saw two different
patterns
rdr1 and three behaved similarly where
they were strongly polarized for
specific genetic backgrounds and
specific geographies
whereas the diversity that we observe
for uh variants with deletions in rdrs 2
and 4
reflected generally speaking the genetic
diversity of the rest of the sequences
that had been deposited within the giza
database
so these deletions were recurrently
arising and the way that we showed this
is using phylogenetics so we took about
100 or so non-deletion viruses that
represented the extent of genetic
diversity of the pandemic within our
study window
and then we produced phylogenys by
aligning those sequences with the
different rdr variants that we had
and so
because these are phylogenetically
interleaved if you look at rdr2 there's
black lines that have no deletions and
red lines with deletions that are all
over the tree suggesting that they'd
arose independently multiple times over
this is true of the other ones
but if you look at rdrs
1 and 3 you can also see that variants
with deletions have been quite prolific
in their spread
suggesting that the deletion variance
can give rise to novel lineages
and we looked over time so throughout
all of this uh deletion variants have
been present at all phases of the
pandemic from the earliest times to to
the end of our study window and i can
say you know even circulating in nature
now
so you can do that by just having a
deletion present at those sites on the
left hand side or on the right-hand side
specific deletions that we saw over and
over again that were characteristic for
this virus
and i think would foreshadowed many of
the things that would come mind you this
was the fall of
2020 before variants had emerged you can
see that different variants of sarsko v2
with the deletion like a delta 6970
could really take off and giving
letting us know that the virus was
capable of making changes and running
with them
i'm a structural biologist by training
and so we looked structurally in these
rdrs mapped to antigenic sites within
the n-terminal domain
at the time we knew about antibody 4a8
and the entire epitope of this
antibodies formed by rdrs 2 and 4.
it doesn't make any contacts outside of
those
the rdr is at least mapped to some low
resolution em maps that christopher
barnes had produced for his work with
pamela bjorkman
so we we engineered different deletion
variants that we were observing both
within our patient and other long-term
infections or were enriched for within
the database into a spike expression
construct and we transfected viral cells
and we could stain those with a mouse
antibody directed to the receptor
binding domain all of them expressed
all of them have the presence of
multi-nucleated sensational bodies
and that tells us that all of these are
functional fusions
wild type cells are on the spike are on
the far right
uh we could then also state co-stain at
the same time with the human isotype of
antibody 488 and we can look at the
overlay below and i think what's quite
clear is that deletions within rdrs2 and
rdrs4
were independently sufficient to disrupt
binding of this antibody and so that
makes sense that these
loops that the antibodies engaging form
the entire epitope for it
using the virus that we isolated from
this long-term infection case
we were able to do neutralization
studies with antibody 4a
where the
viral swarm from that patient was
completely resistant to neutralization
whereas a wild type d614g virus this
munich p3 was entirely
or was neutralized to levels that were
previously reported
a flu specific antibody had no activity
for neutralization
also looked at a panel of convalescent
serums from patients that had survived
infections with sars cov2
it's broken up because the serums had
different potencies and neutralization
so we used similar dilutions with
similar potencies and neutralization on
the wild type virus
and
what we saw is that the mutations at
this site were insufficient to fully
resist neutralization by polyclonal
serum and so i think this was reassuring
to us that one or a few mutations was
insufficient to escape human immunity
so at the time what we knew of is
antibody 4a8 and another one 4-8 that
didn't have a full structure reported
for it
what we now know based on the work of a
lot of different groups is that that
corresponds to the ntd supersite so that
pattern of evolution that we saw was
within this super antigenic site that's
now been resolved in structural detail
but there are other sites within the ntd
that that have focused immune responses
like this site
or ones that overlap with it and when
you put all of the known ntd antibody
structures that had been deposited by
about august of this year
what you can see is that it's clearly
immunogenic there's a lot of different
antibodies that are contacting it in a
lot of different ways
and i think then it's not really
surprising that we're observing the fact
that the ntd is one of the more rapidly
evolving domains or is the most rapidly
evolving domain in the entire spike
protein
and so what i've talked about are these
deletions
what i didn't talk about are that there
are mutations that disrupt antibody
binding glycans have moved around so for
instance the p1 variant first identified
in brazil
has an additional glycan that blocks
some antibodies from binding
there are variants that circulate with
insertions within the ntd and even some
of those have created
new disulfide bonds between loops and
the signal peptides
so because a deletion
can alter multiple amino acids at the
same time
and alter the structures of
the
spike protein that they form it's not
really that surprising then that a
number of variants of concern that have
grabbed attention have incorporated
deletions to into their ntds
and what i'd like to point out is by
using our approach
of looking at patterns of evolution that
were recurrent before these variants
were identified we had already defined
clear phenotypes for what a deletion in
the rdr2 so a delta 144 or 145
or the deletion similar to the ones in
the beta variant that was first
identical identified in south africa so
that b.1.351
and so looking at the variation that
viruses can acquired and transmitted
between people allowed us to apply
figure out quite readily
genotypes and phenotypes for viruses as
sequencing information became available
one thing i'd like to touch back on is
the fact that thinking about this
long-term infection that we we
characterized there were two different
viruses that we we sequenced one with
the deletion at this 145 or 144 position
and then an adjacent position at 146.
and those represent two roads that the
virus took to achieving resistance to to
this four-eight antibody
not only that when we look at this viral
swarm that was isolated from this
patient the entirety of this warmer at
least the vast majority of it wasn't
neutralized because we saw no
neutralization and uh activity by
antibody 488
and in unpublished work what we've
looked at is a second long-term
infection case of somebody who had a
hodgkin lymphoma they were given an
anti-cd19 which would eliminate most of
the b cells
they were also infected for a long
period of time with sars kobe 2 and they
were treated with a monoclonal antibody
from from lily
so that right i can show you what the
structure
of that antibody is it's engaging the
receptor binding domain
and in sequencing that we've done what
we found are some viruses with this e44
q mutation and so this is well described
in the literature and was even found in
the clinical trial but we found a second
set of viruses also within the patient
that had this q um
439k mutation paired with this
serine
494 proline substitution
both of these have also been described
by others but what it does represent is
that the virus was taking multiple
different pathways to resist a
monoclonal antibody
and so while source cov2 may be
relatively slow to introduce mutations
it can readily overcome the focused
antibody response and i think that's an
important lesson is that just because
it's slow to
to mutate its genome it doesn't mean
it's evolutionarily stagnant
and so
this whole approach of using these minor
variants to understand fundamental
aspects about the virus and its
evolution i think is quite powerful and
so what we've been doing since
reporting this deletion story
is studying cases where there's focused
immunity and and looking at transmitted
variants and looking at the diversity
that underlies those sites to figure out
if this were to happen in the future in
a lineage of concern what what's the
consequence of that
and so we began this work with the
receptor binding domain or rbd and i'm
showing that to you in green it's bound
to its receptor h2 which is in white
and so one type of antibody response
that
focused is to this class iv epitope now
the reason why it's uh an interesting
target
is when you consider its conservation
across sarbaco viruses and so what i'm
showing to you on a surface
representation here's conservation
purple being the most conserved and so
the surfaces that these antibodies are
engaging are conserved across all
sarbaco viruses that have been reported
to date
so looking at diversity at this site and
looking for transmitted variants
uh we identified one transmission
cluster involving six or seven people in
the united kingdom they all produced
reasonable ct values that were detected
at the time
and why this is interesting is because
they harbored a deletion at that site so
three amino acids were missing within
that epitope
when we look at a sequence alignment
we can see the deletion right here
the amino acids themselves are invariant
and what i'm showing in red then are
individual mutations they're all
synonymous so they don't change the
coding sequence at all and so it looks
like there's strong pressure to maintain
that stf
you know this this class iv epitope is
really defined by prototypical antibody
cr3022 which was actually isolated from
a patient who survived sars cov1
infection it's a non-neutralizing
antibody which has limited some of the
characterization that we can do
downstream of this
but what we could do is use a mouse
version of antibody 4a
to detect it but we made wild type
expression vectors in those that have a
deletion at this site
we could transfect cells both of them
are fusogenic as shown by the sensation
and on the left-hand panel under 480
and we could then ask whether antibody
cr3022 is capable of binding it and look
at the overlay at the far right of that
slide
and i think what's quite clear is that
this deletion is sufficient to confer
complete resistance to cr3022 binding
if we then look individually at the
structures that i showed you at the
beginning of this part of the talk
all of those that are shown in red make
the correct contacts with those residues
that are conserved and so
based on structural examination
all of the
all these antibodies would have their
binding disrupted or at least
their kd is greatly increased
by the presence of that deletion
and so what i'd like to end up on is
just
you know thinking more broadly about the
evolution of these viruses
so what we looked at are long-term
infections where we were looking at what
was going on with viral evolution and
that informed something about variants
that would future circulate within
nature so what i'm showing you here is
the rdr4 region with the
b.1.351 which was first identified
within south africa
i mean now we know that there's a lot
more things going on here there's
mutations there's insertions there's
other deletions that are occurring
and if we look more broadly uh across
sarbaco viruses this is a site that
tolerates an extreme amount of genetic
diversity
so the same patterns we're seeing in
stars kovi two evolution were observed
for uh multiple different bat and
pangolin or human sarbaco viruses
there are other sites in spike then that
do the same thing that are very tolerant
of insertions deletions mutations and
iterating cycles thereof and so the site
that i'm showing you here is the syrian
cleavage site
and there's been a lot of discussion as
to how the sars kobe 2 has a fear
insight and some other viruses related
to it don't
but i'd like to make the point and i
don't have answers for how any of this
came to be is that if you look carefully
enough what i'm showing you under rdr4
is that just out of thin air
a similar rrxr motif could just be
introduced by a random insertion right
there's four codons for uh glycine or or
alanine in the case of the natural one
there's six codons for arginine and so
these things will happen
now what i can say about the ones that
we that we're looking at in rdr4 it
doesn't appear to be processed as best
we can tell so reagents for that are a
little bit limited
um it didn't spread beyond a handful of
people and it's since gone extinct but
what it does show us is that iterating
cycles of insertions deletions and
mutations can produce
the types of mutations that could be
instantly beneficial for these sorts of
viruses and that's something to watch
for
and so just to wrap up i think deletions
do represent a rapid evolutionary
mechanism especially one that a virus
that has a proofreading polymerase can
employ
again you can't proofread a deletion
because there's nothing to compare
against
this clearly can alter the antigen
antigenicity of the spike glycoprotein
but we've also seen deletions come into
play where there's recurrent deletion of
specific residues within nsp6 which is
in the polymerase so that's been
acquired in a number of variants of
concern
and also anybody who's tried to grow
this virus on viral cells for a long
period of time that the virus doesn't
like its fear and cleavage site in those
cells and so it usually deletes it
rather than mutates it
what our work did shine light on to is
the fact that the ntd is very
immunogenic and rapidly evolving right
it's this malleable domain that can
tolerate an extreme amount of genetic
diversity
and this is going to be problematic for
antibodies that are directed to this
domain and how we think about vaccine
design and displaying the types of
proteins to the immune system that are
invariant versus those that are highly
variable
um and i do think that there is value in
looking at the tips of the phylogenetic
trees and understanding what's the
diversity that's being transmitted
person to person
uh even at low levels and what is that
telling us about the mutability of the
virus because if we've learned anything
it's that when the mutations that
benefit this virus are usually
recurrently then introduced right in the
case of n501y that's happened multiple
times over
similarly with e4k
similarly with the deletions again and
so because of the convergence of
evolution of these viruses
you know looking at the complex series
of changes that give genetic novelty i
think is quite informative
and so with that i'd like to thank a lot
of people who've contributed to this
work and their names will be up here on
the slide i'd like to thank all of you
for paying attention and i'll be
answering questions by email and
attending the session so thank you very
much